Speaker 1: the continued bad news for
the failed former president Donald Trump
in an appeals court now says the Department of
Justice can resume its criminal probe of the
classified documents that were obtained at Mar
a Lago. Remember, once that search warrant was
executed and the documents were taken, seized, the
Trump side said, we need a special master. There's
medical documents in there. There's privileged
documents in there. Special master is going to
look at all of it and, you know, classified,
declassified, just a complete and total mess.
We are now moving beyond that. As CNN reports,
a federal appeals court is allowing the
Justice Department to continue looking at those
documents marked classified seized from Trump.
The emergency intervention upends a trial judge's
order over those documents that had blocked
federal investigators work on the documents and
is a strong rebuke of the Trump team's attempt to
suggest, without evidence, that materials were
somehow declassified. Remember what happened?
The special master said, Listen. If you're going
to make this argument about classification,
then make it and we're going to move on very
quickly if you don't, because the special
master said, which I told you two days ago,
you give me a document that says Top secret.
And you don't present any evidence that it
was declassified. That's it. Essentially a
cut the crap moment. And that is exactly what is
going on here. The ruling was issued by a three
judge panel of the 11th U.S. Circuit Court of
Appeals. Two of the three judges were nominated
by Donald Trump. This is supposed to be quite
a conservative court. And it really goes to
show that the arguments Trump was making in
public were completely and totally absurd.
Perhaps the funniest line from the entire thing
is, quote, For our part, we cannot discern why
the plaintiff would have an individual interest
in or need for any of the 100 documents with
classification markings. And that sort of says it
all. We can't figure that out as well. It was for
Trump's memoirs. He doesn't read or write. Trump
wanted to review the documents. He doesn't read or
write. They were for Trump's library. The library
is not even something Trump is really thinking of,
according to many insiders. There's just no
reasonable explanation other than bad ones.
He wanted to sell them. He wanted to use them as
leverage. Horrible, horrible things that border
on treason. The judges couldn't understand that
either. So the investigation continues. There
is now an indictment watch taking place. We'll
see where we are another month or two from now.